alors cette fermeture elle provoque des
remous à fessenheim nous avait
d'ailleurs assisté à la conférence de
presse du collectif des associations
environnementales à colmar le réacteur
numéro un a bel et bien été débranché
hier par edf et cette fermeture est bien
elle provoque des remous et les avis
divergent ce matin plusieurs
associations environnementales ont
accordé une conférence de presse andré
axe membres du collectif stop stop
fessenheim qui milite depuis des années
pour la fermeture de cette centrale au
nucléaire se dit lui soulagé écoutez le
je n'ai pas vu une victoire c'est un
soulagement
effectivement c'est un soulagement parce
que depuis 50 ans depuis la construction
nous attendions ce jour là mais il
faudra encore être très prudents
jusqu'au 30 juin date de l'arrêt du
deuxième réacteur et bien au delà parce
qu'il y aura du combustible hautement
irradiait qui sera stockée dans les
piscines l'extérieur pendant trois ans
plus de 200 tonnes de combustible c'est
très grave alors que le bâtiment n'est
pas bien qu'arrivée nous sommes aussi en
colère parce que hier les ministres qui
sont venus ont commis une erreur
politique majeure en annonçant la
construction dans technocentre à
fessenheim elles se sont mises une balle
dans le pied
aucun industriel aucune start up ne
voudra s'installer à côté d'un
ferrailleur qui traite des vaches y est
irradié elisabeth borde la ministre de
la transition écologique était présente
hier à colmar elle estime que c'est un
grand pas dans la transition écologique
écoutez là avec la reconversion que nous
engageons fessenheim restera une terre
d'excellence porté par l'innovation par
des industries de pointe 1 et par
l'économie de la transition écologique
avec cette fermeture nous fait
franchissons un grand pas dans la
transition énergétique
donc dans le changement de modèle de
production de l'électricité
à fessenheim l'ambiance est plutôt
différente a les mêmes morose puisque
les habitants sont déçus entier pour
l'avenir ils craignent la perte donc pas
nous avons pu leur parler je vous
propose de les écouter
elle demande aux travaux de fait
maintenant c'est dommage de fermer
puisque ça a été réactualisé refaire
mais bon on savait qu'elle fermerait en
jour c'est la plus vieille de france on
va déçu on est là parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de monde qui vaut par un perdre
leur emploi alors c'est déjà la perte
d'emplois et déjà pour le commerce et
tout ça c'est vraiment c'est très
difficile de la vie économique du de
tout le secteur va en pâtir
c'est évident un des magasins des
restaurants c'est parce que ça va
devenir nos biens immobiliers est ce que
les prix vont baisser ou pas vous l'avez
entendu les avis divergent il ya les
antinucléaires il ya ceux qui sont pour
cette centrale nucléaire car elle
apporter du travail pour la ville et les
environs quoi qu'il en soit le
démantèlement va être long il doit se
poursuivre jusqu'en 2040
merci beaucoup monnaie avons dès lors
pour toutes ces précisions